crypto derivatives platform and the best
place to buy your bitcoin
hey guys and welcome back to the leia
hill pan show as always today we're
bringing you another incredible
conversation which you really can't find
anywhere else on the internet right now
because censorship is rife and we are
bringing you the most
hot i guess we could call it some of the
most controversial the hottest topics um
going on um in the world right now but
before i do bring on my guess i do want
to let you know that this podcast is
sponsored by bitmex and bitmex is the og
crypto derivatives exchange and now
actually has a spot exchange for you to
easily buy and sell your crypto
especially in a bear market you do need
a name that you can trust and bitmex
sets a standard in reliability
performance and transparency and it's
actually proven itself through multiple
uh market cycles and this is very
important um with the amount of
liquidations we're seeing going on right
now um bimx is actually celebrating the
start of bimx spot with one million
dollars in usd prizes so to enter all
you have to do is trade the equivalent
of 250 us dollars so you could grab some
bitcoin during the crash so i'm gonna
leave all that information for you um in
the description if you are watching on
youtube it will be in the description so
definitely check out bitmex now before i
bring on today's guest i want to tell
you please don't forget to hit the
subscribe button and hit the like button
because without you guys we wouldn't be
able to bring you such incredible
conversations so joining me today is the
founder and director of the trends
research institute and publisher of the
weekly trends journal magazine he's the
author of the highly acclaimed and
best-selling books trend tracking and
trends 2000. it is gerald celente gerald
welcome to the show how are you
i'm very well thank you so much for
having me on
it's such a pleasure i am so excited um
i've been following everything you do
and everything you talk about for a
really long time
um and there's a lot of synergies here
um and i like
can you hear me okay
you can't hear me
yep
can you hear me okay
guys let me know in the comments if you
can hear me
you can't hear me
all right guys let me know in the
comments if it's me or if if it's gerald
let me see
um audio
um
can you turn your volume up
yep
can you hear me
you're broking up and the thing is
stagnant here
oh i think everyone can hear me but i'm
not sure that you can um i don't hear
you
you don't hear me i can hear you
perfectly they can hear both of us i
don't know why you can't hear me all
right let's um
i'm gonna i'm gonna end the broadcast
and i'm gonna go again okay
all right hang on
can you hear me now i can hear you now
perfect i don't know what happened um
they could hear me so
there you go um all right well i want to
just kick this off let's just do it what
do you say about the current situation
right now um are we in a recession i
know they keep sort of changing the
definition of what a recession is um so
i want to get your take on it
of course we're in a recession i mean
look look who's saying we're not in a
recession
janet yellen oh janet yellen who's janet
yellen oh you mean janet yellen that
used to be that the head of the bankster
gang called the federal reserve
or that janet yellen that's now the
treasury secretary
of the united states what imbecilland
[ __ ] can't see who's running the
country
the banksters are right there
oh the janet yellen that was yelling
back oh back in april of 2021
celenti you and all of you others that
say there's inflation out there why how
stupid you are
it's only temporary
and then it became
transitory
and now she's saying the recession is
a transition
oh yeah how about trent
temporary transitory
transitionatory and how about
transgender
really be america today
be inclusive
let's really be stupid and keep
swallowing the crap
keeps oh oh she's our treasury secretary
your honor
oh yeah
look at the garbage they're shoving out
the people are going down the crapper we
write about it each week in the trends
journal how many can't pay their bills
oh the debt level
oh americans are only over 16 trillion
dollars in debt barely could pay off
their credit cards living paycheck to
paycheck hey
but the fink guy over there at blackrock
oh look at all the money they're making
oh and how about blackstone or why you
are being sexist a racist excuse me
you got the wrong one
blackstone oh yeah what are they buying
up all these companies buying up all the
housing so the workers of slave landia
could rent them because they can't
afford to buy them
what recession is it's over we are in
the greatest financial
socioeconomic and geopolitical crisis
in
the history of the world part one and
part two
so for you this is clearly very obvious
um why do you think that
janet yellen and the likes of all of
those types of people um are lying uh
saying that it's transitory either do
they just not know are they just stupid
or are they bad people what do you think
a combination of all three
again
again once upon a time there was a story
about somebody by the name of jesus
christ
yes he becomes violent he becomes the
prince of peace becomes violent makes a
whip you couldn't buy him at walmart's
back then and drives the money changers
out of the temple
oh you mean the goldman sachs gang hey
was jamie diamond's great great great
great great great great grandfather
there oh the goldman sachs gang the
merrill lynch mob
what are you kidding
it's it's a crime organization it's a
crime syndicate anybody that calls this
a government is really stupid deaf dumb
and blind by the deed you shall know
them hey jamie diamond you're too big to
fail i'm obama the nobel peace or crap
prize winner i want that guy qaddafi i
want the guy who sought out of that oh
yeah that obama here you're too big to
fail here's a couple of billion dollars
100 a couple hundred billion and the
federal reserve dumping in 29 trillion
between 2007 and 2010
to bail out the banksters
oh no that's not my number that's from
the levy institute at bard college
it's a crime syndicate
they could care less about us the bigs
are getting bigger they own everything
when i was a young guy
they had things called drug stores
grocery stores stationary stores
hardware stores no more all chains now
the mom and pop slaughtered but the bigs
bought everything all of those private
equity groups yeah yeah all of those
hedge funds none of that existed
when i was a young man
you use the term banksters um i love
that term but
for those that don't know could you sort
of get into the detail of what you would
say the biggest issue is with the banks
you know what makes them so criminal
well they're because oh they're only
concerned about themselves again look
what they did
you know they artificially propped up
the markets oh by the way jesus christ
after he drove the money changes out of
the temple
on the cross three days later
all right
it's a crime syndicate it was made up by
another slimy rotten hell piece of
garbage crap
woodrow wilson
the slime ball that got us into world
war one
the guy that gave us the federal income
tax we didn't have him back until he
came in in the 19 was in 1913 1912
it's a crime syndicate they control
everything
all we are are workers of slave landia
oh they won't we're gonna do away with
the glass-steagall act oh yeah we're
going to let the the gangsters uh
banksters gamble too oh don't worry
about it if you lose money uh don't
we'll pay we'll bail you out
you know don't buy their deeds you shall
know them
they get us into wars they steal our
money how could anybody with a brain
bigger than a pee look up to these
clowns who's your favorite little chucky
schumer no i like nancy pelosi oh no
lindsey graham now there's a nitwit for
me oh how about ted cruz no no mitch
mcconnell how could you be so damn
stupid
they keep using the term stagflation but
you're more interested in the term drag
fellation
what's the difference
oh yeah of course you're not allowed to
say drag children the babies can say it
the children are allowed to say it and
drag queen story hour and all that
rubbish but um but
what's the difference drag flashing
means the economy's dragging down and
inflation's going up and they're still
selling the lie of stagflation going
back to the federal reserve why they do
it they did it when they launched the
covent war first of all let's go back to
2018.
okay tracking trends is the
understanding of where we are how we got
here and where we're going let's go back
to december 2018.
once upon a time a guy by the name of
donald trump a narcissistic guy was
president of the united states the
presidential reality show
the economies the markets are crashing
in december of 2018.
for months months months day after day
trump is going after jerome powell the
fed head to lower interest rates to
artificially boost up the markets
and they did
go back to 2019 remember the repo
disaster from september
2019 to january 2020
the federal reserve dumped in
some 10 trillion dollars into the repo
markets
this thing was going down
it was artificially propped up before
the covenant war then the covenant was
oh and the prostitutes the media wars
that get paid to put out by the
corporate pimps and the government [ __ ]
masters they're blaming the problems now
quote on the pandemic anything that
happens this negative depend no not the
pandemic the political scum that locked
us down the little dick tasters
dictators in a country near you a mayor
senator whatever governor
prime minister whatever whatever that
not the pandemic the people who did it
the damage that's been caused by the
covenant war is incalculable
let's go back to why they were lying or
stupid about interest rates
and not raising them because then the
federal reserve besides the united
states dumping in
about 6.5 trillion dollars to
artificially juice the markets
and there's no inflation that fake money
didn't mean anything
the federal reserve brings the interest
rates down to zero
they're artificially propped up the
equity markets in 2020 and 2021 when
they should have been crashing
look at the businesses that have gone
out of business
how how about the office occupancy rate
well it's only about 40 percent in
america you mean 60 of office buildings
aren't filled anymore
yeah
oh what's going to happen to all those
officers that they were overbuilt before
oh oh and interest rates are going up
and now you got to pay more on your loan
oh and interest rates are going up and
the debt level in the united states is
over 30 trillion dollars you have to pay
more
oh but the dollar is doing well let's go
to europe
how about the clown running the show
over there oh god where'd she come from
oh the imf before that you mean the
international mafia monetary fund
oh oh
there's no inflation she said as well
what did they have negative interest
rates
hey all you people of slave landia when
i was a young man we used to put our
money in the banks and get
interest on it
now they just steal your money they
don't give you anything for it but they
make money on it negative interest rates
and now they're bragging that they
brought them up to zero oh and your
inflation rate is only eight point six
percent oh if you're a member of the inf
la god
and you loan money to a country the god
they gotta raise their interest rates
one percentage point above inflation the
god
that means the interest rates in the eu
the god should be 9.6
and in
america they should be 10.1 percent with
your inflation rate coming out at 9.1
percent
it's a crime syndicate they're only
interested in the thinks of blackrock
their only interested in the hedge funds
the private equity groups that own
everything
that's all they care about their money
junkies
so i'm gonna get into all of i want to
get deeper into this um but before we do
i want to know what's the difference in
your opinion then between where we're at
now um with this recession and 2008
because i've seen people are still
actually spending now as if we're not in
a recession completely different to 2008
so what's the difference here the
difference is all the businesses that
have been destroyed the lives and
livelihoods of billions of people that
have been destroyed with a two and a
half year almost going on
the oh two and a half year war of the
cold war
again you have an office occupancy rate
of 40 right
how about all those businesses that
depended on a thing called commuters
oh you mean the dry cleaners the shoe
repair the the hair store oh
oh oh happy hours gone
gone dead
dead
all the businesses that have gone out of
business
they're not coming back oh it'll come
back maybe you should say that it'll
come back the damage that has been done
now let's go to the big picture
interest rates going up right all over
the world crazy okay now
other place called sri lanka that nobody
heard of until it made the news
yeah how about all those other emerging
markets
oh you mean all those emerging markets
that borrowed all that money in dollars
and now interest rates are going up and
their currencies are going down
those those places
oh yeah what's going to happen to them
this is a global crisis
and then you have the the idiocy with
the ukraine war going on and all the
sanctions that they put on russia quote
to punish putin are punishing the
let's go back to those emerging markets
that are all submerging
look at look at how
this i'm telling you we are in the worst
geopolitical and socio-economic crisis
of a lifetime i've been in this business
of 42 years
i'm very concerned about what's going on
because my business is to look ahead
and then what concerns you though what
is it specifically that's concerning you
again when people lose everything and
have nothing left to lose they lose it
look at the crime rates going up
and then the biggest concern right now
of course
is world war iii it's begun yeah
it's not going to become official until
there's a nuclear exchange some false
flag matter of fact this week the
russian defense minister said the
ukraine defense minister admitted that
the united states is on the field
helping the ukrainians fire these
missiles
so it's not a proxy war
we're at war with russia if you i said
to you listen give me some guns i want
to blow this guy's brains out across the
street and you gave me the guns and i
blew his brains out you're an accessory
to the crime yeah america's at war with
russia
again they the idiots see have how they
they brainwash us when we're kids
world war one little girls and boys
began when they assassinated the
archduke ferdinand sarajevo
what calls an archduke and where's the
sarajevo or what is
it was going on long before that world
war ii started with a japanese bomb
pearl harbor i mean nothing was going on
before that you mean fdr didn't close
off all the china's exports and dan oil
going in there oh no no
it only happened when they bombed pearl
harbor
it had where at world war three
when they asked albert einstein a cat
that knew a thing or two about the atom
bomb what kind of weapons are going to
be used to fight the third world war
he said i don't know but they'll be
using sticks and stones to fight the
fourth
we have
mentally ill people
running and ruining our lives how low
can you go to look up to a biden how
stupid can you be to little katson
nobody arrogant little boy mac crone
over there in france remember the jerk
they had that our great
great illustrator artist that does the
covers of the trends journal anthony
frieda if i said freda listen
get me a cartoon character i want to
make him the prime minister of the uk he
couldn't have come up with a freakier
looking stupid jerk clown like boris
johnson
look at the idiots the imbeciles the
mentally ill freaks that are running and
ruining our lives
world war ii is not ancient history
world war one is not ancient history
we got sick people
mentally deranged people that are
destroying the lives and livelihoods of
billions i'm little gavin newsom another
daddy's boy i'm locking down california
hey
um yes sir yes sir rule out the red
carpet yes sir how can you believe these
crap heads how can you believe a little
georgie bush another daddy's boy born on
third base and thought he had a home run
we're gonna get osama bin laden get her
alive oh yeah and 88 of people swallowed
the crap and we invaded afghanistan for
20 years oh those russians oh the same
george bush we're going to get that guy
we got to get
what was the guy's name uh which one
hussein
oh saddam hussein
destruction entire calcada a lie an
outright lie
oh but hey he's the president he could
lie and by the way little georgie bush
said and he tried to kill my daddy he
actually said
this is the imbeciles we got
oh and don't forget to roll out the red
carpet bro and salute and all these
generals generals miley in general
mad dog mattis with all of their all of
their
military drag
emblems grow the hell up what are you in
boy scouts sewn off all this crap
oh i'm with you i want to i want to get
back to russia and ukraine just for a
second because you mentioned um how the
sanctions are supposedly supposed to
harm putin but um that's not quite the
case so you've spoken a lot about swift
and how actually taking russia off swift
isn't necessarily the best idea um so i
want to understand more about this wall
that people don't sort of realize where
we're in right now
this is the magazine cover
of the trends journal
back in 2014
happy face there right it's the
overthrow of the democratically elected
government of viktor yanukovych by the
united states with victoria newland
and others
because
yanukovych wanted to do a deal
with the imf in the eu because ukraine
has been broke since the breakup of the
soviet union the european union called
ukraine the most corrupt country in
europe
the european union
the clown boy that's playing president
zielinski you can't make this crap up
what did he do before he became
president oh he played the president of
the ukraine on his sitcom
oh and also played the piano with his
penis oh that guy
yeah
all right
he came in because he said he was going
to get rid of the oligarchs
and bring get rid of corruption and his
member of the club the guardian even did
a story about it after he got elected
so
people have no idea of
what happened in ukraine
how the united states overthrew it
the lies that were told oh again the
deal was he was going to do a deal with
the imf and and the eu and putin said i
got a better deal for you i'll give you
lower interest rates and i'll cut your
gas prices okay we'll go with you that
was the overthrow
and then the other things
after when the war started germany and
france came out with the minsk agreement
where that separatist region where the
people had voted for yanukovych didn't
want to go
with the overthrow government
they were going to be a separate area
but ukraine ended up killing and even
zielinski admitted it last week we wrote
about the trends journal
the ongoing
war that began in 2014 in the donbass
region where they killed 15 000 people
there
number three
the
breakup of the soviet union the deal was
between gorbachev and reagan and
gorbachev and bush senior that quote
nato would not move one inch further
there were 16 european nations now
they're about 30.
and by the way we would love it if the
russians were up in
canada with missiles aimed at us and the
chinese were down in
mexico with missiles aimed at us and
they were doing continually
naval
drills off the coast of new york and
california we would love that hey but
america could do it we're bringing
freedom and democracy
read the book wars a racket by general
smedley butler the most decorated marine
in american history at the time 1935
he warns
what a disgusting country countries
become with the wars being launched by
the banksters and the other bandits
and how what he had to do to bring
standard oil into china and the brown
brothers so they could do deals in haiti
and cuba on and on
you think the united states would have
invaded a rock
and be in eastern
syria and take over libya
if their major export was broccoli
probably probably not but what do you
think about then the last two years um
given let's see what like you know the
the lockdowns and the money printing how
um because obviously you're laughing at
the lockdown so um how intertwined is
that i did speak to somebody who
mentioned that
they said that the recession never ever
went away and they used the last two
years as an excuse for an inevitable
economy which was just ready to collapse
so what's your take on the last two
years they're 100 right as i said they
go by the data the economy was ready to
collapse it was like been artificially
pumped up since 2008.
you know you know solenta you got it
wrong in 2012 you said it was going to
go down again yeah you're right i got it
wrong they didn't teach me about a thing
called quantitative easing or zero
interest rate policy in economics 101 or
graduate school they made this crap up
america has and europe have become
communist fascist nations
and that's not just a line i'll tell you
the why
on the communist side
when the covenant war broke out
on january 20th
2020 in china the year of the rat
the first thing they did was lock down
everything and what did they do they
locked down hong kong i used to be on
hong kong tv in 2019 you had a million
people taking to the streets at a city
of 7.5 million can't get a million
people to take the streets in america at
332 million because they were fighting
against
chinese taking over the hong kong yeah
the covered war breaks out they lock
down hong kong pass the security act and
that's the end of it what happens next
we used to make fun of the chinese for
wearing masks yeah
they locked down the place
and then you got the clown over there in
italy locked down italy and then one
country after another followed so he
became the chinese way
yeah and all of these little dictators
governors
locking down making up crap i mean how
can you be so damn stupid look at that
little clown the open the governor of
ohio dewine witness whitmer in michigan
hogan another daddy's boy over there in
maryland little andy cuomo another
daddy's boy in new york oh they even
gave the clown an emmy they gave him an
emmy from spewing out his crap so well
during the covert war
they destroyed the economy
and artificially juiced it up with the
fake money and negative and zero
interest rates
that's where we're at
and they the economy again you go to new
york before
2020
and there were four rent signs
everywhere in 2009 right so that's on
the communist side
on the fascist side
a guy by the name of benito mussolini
called fascism
the merger of state and corporate powers
hey we're gonna buy them corporate bonds
you you're just a piece of crap hey
but we'll buy you bonds you're a member
of the club
oh and how about
one after another look at the new deal
they just did
we got to make chips in the united
states and we'll get these big companies
your money so they can make chips hey
how about giving me money you're just a
piece of garbage no tax breaks for you
nothing for you
oh and by the way nobody talks about the
slime ball the biggest slime ball that
made
little billy clinton a little nobody
nafta remember nafta
oh yeah
oh how about bringing china into the
world trade organization you look at
china's gdp from 1970 till they came
into the
wto a few days bef two weeks after 9 11
their gdp skyrockets oh and the crap
they used to sell us
we don't want those dirty manufacturing
jobs in america we're going to we're
going to make a service sector society
we're going to get rid of them so now
you could you could become a plantation
worker at walmarts i remember when they
were fighting not to have walmart's is a
brand new invention only happened really
big time like it in in the uh
the lat it started in the late 70s early
80s
and then all the big they did away with
the robbers batman exterminator justin
clayton anthony trust that
glass-steagall act gave everything to
the bigs
so it's all connected
it's all connected
there's something very important by the
way going on in in russia one of our top
trends in 2020
too
is self-sufficiency
russia is going against globalization
russia's going against globalization yep
oh oh mcdonald's pulled out of russia oh
great they should have forced mcdonald's
to save russia so the people would have
been become too fat to fight like in
america
you know and all these companies leaving
russia so other russian companies are
going to take their place russia has all
of the human and natural resources they
need to be a self-sufficient nation
america used to be a self-sufficient
nation before the bill clinton's and the
other slime balls sold us out why do you
think the goldman sachs gang would
spend give bill clinton 300 000
to [ __ ] for one hour
it's payback
you can hear the night [ __ ] for free
so
saying is rush we are going into an end
of globalization
in a big way with russia but the worst
part is
if we don't have
another
american revolution for freedom to break
us away from the communist and fascist
dictators that have taken over our lives
i'll tell you what to say you have no
right to say what i don't want to say
yeah i am an authority and you have to
believe what i believe anything that you
don't believe that i believe is
misinformation
which by the way i think that's a sexist
word misinformation is it oh because
guys are missing it
it's all sexist um
information you know yeah yeah a little
bit about it yeah no no i'm with you um
so i i it's interesting i definitely
agree with you i i can see the trend
that's going on in the west in america
the uk you know you're not allowed to
say this you can't say that social media
um it it's truly um
incredible but what i
what i want to understand and get your
your uh your take on is why are we
adopting the the chinese way right like
you mentioned the masks the lockdown
like we're doing what china is doing and
we'll get to central bank digital
currencies in a minute because obviously
they have their digital yuan um so i
thought we don't like china why are we
doing what china's doing
it's a nation
because these these are power hungry
freaks that are in charge
and they use the power to to be more
control at 26 years old
i was the assistant to the secretary of
the new york state senate the guy that
ran the whole show
nice man al abrams
i got i got on the inside
i was running major political campaigns
in westchester county at that time the
richest county in the united states
they were grooming me
it was the worst job i ever had
i quit after one year
i'd be you know a young guy you know
bsing in the back of the chamber and we
got a clown we hire a slobby clown to
open the door for these freaks to walk
in senator frank smith
senator tom ellis senator hey what's the
matter man can't guy can't open the door
by himself and then my friends would
leave me as we're talking have a talking
and they follow the senator's seat these
big seats you could blow on them and
they move
pull it out and help them sit down
and they come back i say man what's the
matter cat can't sit down by himself he
needs some help he said you know gerald
you have that kind of an attitude you're
not going to make it here
that's not the way i grew up man you
know i'm a napolitano born in the bronx
i got a different vibe than you catch
you know my good buddy donahue his wife
mary donahue became the lieutenant
governor under on the pataki
i i was the chief government affairs
specialist for the chemical industry
at 28 years old i was staying at the
willard hotel and putting meetings on at
a hey adams i was killing environmental
legislation at the height of the
environmental movement in the 70s
reagan
presidents prime ministers and
presidents i've been with them
so what's your take then
if i wasn't on the other side i wouldn't
know what's going on
so what i say to you what's going on
is we have mentally ill power-hungry
freaks who've never worked a day in
their lives that are running and ruining
hours
okay
and how how deep does this go um
because people often
link everything back to money like you
know we mentioned covered that there's a
lot of people in the comments i'm
reading now that say covered was a scam
the lockdowns were a scam um so how deep
does this go um people often look to
world economic forum class schwab and
what's your what's your take oh it's all
of it and again
look at the guy look at the guy playing
our defense contractor
lloyd austin
and where was he a defense country came
from the military oh yeah general lloyd
hosts where yes sir the lloyd austin
that just came
that was sitting on the board of
directors of raytheon
the second largest defense contractor
in the united states
that keeps shooting off his mouth to how
russia has to be
defeated it's not a revolving door
they're in charge
oh how about the clown that just left
the fda food and drug administration
oh you mean a jerk that was the head of
tobacco area that would regulate east
cigarettes and tobacco where did he just
go to
philip morris
their total control
this is in america it's comi fascist
town again
by the facts the merger of state and
corporate powers and the commie little
freaks
that robbed us of our freedom and rights
you got to get that vaccination hey how
about that arrogant arrogant boy
the carnival boy the clinton crapster
that shoots off his mouth
that shot his mouth off james carver
james a jimmy boy
that shot off his mouth i'd like to
punch the [ __ ] out of anybody that
doesn't want to get vaccinated
yeah that they put out there come and
try to punch the [ __ ] out of me
oh oh and i didn't get vast oh but biden
did for thousands four times obama did
clinton did they all got covered and boy
i'm all happy i got the vexes and got
the boosters because i i i got i got
covered but i could have died
it's true i'm with you i totally agree
with you if i didn't got covered and
then he got it again and then he got it
again with all his different uh booster
shots when did the change happen though
because america was supposed to be you
know the land of the free you come here
you know the whole red scare god forbid
you're a communist like what happened or
would you say it's always sort of been
there
i have a photograph i'll tell you when
it changed okay
1963.
it was november
it's a week before my birthday i'm born
on the 29th so it's okay what's how many
days before that 21 the 17th what is it
when they assassinated jfk
oh well that's when it changed that's
when it changed
you read dwight d eisenhower's farewell
address
january
17
1961.
he warns the american people that the
military-industrial complex is robbing
the nation the genius of the scientists
the sweater labors and the future of the
children
read his address he said this never
happened there was no other military
complex after world war one world war ii
in the korean war
this is a general
a five-star general supreme commander of
the allied forces in world war ii again
a two-term president who's also quoted
as saying
any man seeking the office of president
is either an egomaniac or crazy
i have a photograph
it's right over here if you want me to
get i'll get it
of john connolly and his wife nelly
john connelly and that we're in front of
the book depository where kennedy was
allegedly assassinated from
1992
he wanted to meet me because in one of
my books trend tracking i had forecasts
that'd be a new third party and someone
like ross perot would be the guy i wrote
it in eight and nine and perot became
the guy
we we're in front of the anatole hotel
in front of the book depository
in a limousine and this is the guy that
took the bullet in the back sitting in
front of kennedy
he also as the governor of texas he also
became
the treasury secretary under richard
nixon
that took us off the gold standard yeah
we're walking back into the anatole
hotel
and he said to me you know gerald he
said i read your book he says a fine
piece of work
and i know your heart's in the right
place
but you don't have a clue what's going
on
and neither the american people
because if they did
there'd be a revolution in this country
you asked me what happened
that slime ball lbj did he get
did he just get
uh what's his name kennedy assassinated
because right after kennedy's
assassinated the vietnam war you're
asking me what happened to america
i was prime draft meeting those days
every day i wake up every day they're
going to get me they're going to get me
if we don't stop those cha those
commies in vietnam those dominoes are
going to keep falling and before you
know it those communists are going to
take over the world
all the asia first
58 thousand americans were killed we
killed over three million
vietnamese poison the place with agent
orange
friends of mine you can't mention the
word vietnam they're so heartbroken and
they remember the what had happened
there
250 000 seriously wounded
and america's talking about russia and
they're selling the same line if we
don't stop those russians over there in
ukraine
before you know it there's going to be a
war they're going to be taking over
europe oh you mean the ukraine where
they're taking down the statue with
catherine the great because catherine
the great hated the ukraines according
to them oh and when was katherine the
greater round you mean the 1750s you
mean this crap has been going on from
the 1750s and now you're telling me i
gotta get involved in this
you ask me when america went down
when they killed kennedy
and then you look at all the things that
that that that johnson did
it was guns and butter guns and butter
america was the most thriving industrial
nation in the world the other ones have
still been destroyed
and what does he do he's they changed
the immigration well i had cousins from
italy they couldn't come in
they changed the immigration law to get
cheap labor
butter yeah give them put out a lot of
free money over there shut them up shut
them up shut them up
one after another they just and then
then they they destroyed the country
and it just kept on going
and then war on terror
yeah one after another
and now we're going into world war three
i'm heartbroken
i'm heartbroken to see where the future
is going
you know where do you think it's going
it's going to hell with hell on earth
every damn day oh nancy pelosi went to
to tell what the hell are you doing over
there in taiwan yeah my business
oh oh and we're going to defend taiwan
oh you're going to go defend them you
mean after your husband starts finishes
doing inside deals and making millions
then what's your family worth about 500
million bucks oh and my daddy was mayor
of baltimore oh and he was congressman
in in maryland and my brother was mayor
of baltimore i'm a member of the club
i never worked a day in my life
i've been in the political system
i'll tell you what to do
this is america
i'll tell you what to do
i'm your governor i'm your mayor
i'm your president do what i tell you to
do get that vaccination or go to hell
lose your job this is america
i'm heartbroken
so what do you do what do we do how do
you how do you change the course i can i
launched occupy peace
i had a huge rally over here in january
july 23rd i own the most historic four
buildings in america the only place with
pre-revolutionary war stone buildings i
bought them because the siege of
democracy was sown here
i had judge napolitano
gary no god progressive radio network
scott ritter
phil giraldi former cia guy
music the hot damn band streets pack
pack packed close down the streets
not one word in the media
you think i did this for me
you think i spent all this money and put
all my energy into this
for me
i want to bring peace this i am an
american
i believe in people like george
washington
who tells us no foreign entanglements
and particularly warning us not to get
involved in all the crap in europe
and don't love a country don't hate a
country you're an american this is your
country oh you're an isolationist no
[ __ ] you want to go to ukraine go
fight you want to send your money oh we
only said 60 billion already as the
nation's going down the crapper you said
your money don't want mine going there i
honor the founding fathers i honor
dwight d eisenhower
screw you
where the hell are they don't you know
who i am
i'm gavin newsom yeah
we sent out thousands and thousands of
press releases
over the course of three weeks not even
local coverage
peace is forbidden
so anyway you asked me what i'm doing
i'm doing everything i can because if we
don't unite for peace we're going to die
in war
and do you think that so i mean given
everything that you said it sounds like
you think america is is is on the
downtrend massively you know it used to
be you know like we've had the british
empire we saw that collapse the roman
empire saw that collapse the american
empire um i imagine you see that
collapsing so what are the new
superpowers it's collapsed already these
arrogant generals you guys haven't won a
war since world war ii
shove your crap down your throat stop
killing people and stealing my money to
do it
calm down celenti don't be angry be a
good american
bend over and swallow the crap
swallow the crap
i got one of my tenants over here in the
1774 academy a place called rough draft
i redid the whole place
they had a sign on their day they locked
down they closed down when the rally
began because it was a political rally
these are the people that made you be
vaccinated to sit down and stay there it
wasn't a political rally
nothing about politics nothing about
political parties nothing about
politicians
about peace and freedom
what america's founding fathers fought
for that had been stolen from us in
front of our eyes
in front of our eyes
he who is not angry when there is just
cause for anger is immoral
why
because anger looks for the good of
justice
and if you can live amid injustice
without anger
you
are immoral
as well as
unjust
said
saint thomas aquinas
so that's where you're at that's where
i'm at
that's where you're at i agree
you know this is baloney i used to teach
close combat had my own school for many
years
yeah i'm a real fighter and i don't get
in fights i only attack the attacker
so when i say
you want me to do what you're i'm not
gonna swallow your crap
newsome i'm not gonna swallow your crap
cuomo i had rallies here
when everything was locked down in july
of 2020
for freedom peace and justice
yep
they hate me
they hate me in kingston they hate
salenti because he's a man
of freedom peace and justice he doesn't
tell you what to do
but you hate him because he won't
swallow the crap that you eat
he won't bend down and bend over to take
it up from the politicians whose
you look up to
that's america
and my generation the biggest sellouts
the biggest sellouts the only reason
they were protesting during the vietnam
wars because we were getting drafted
where are they now
but not all my generation i mean a lot
of the cats that we hear were you know
older people
most of them more older people and
younger people
but the whole the whole game changed
when they assassinated kennedy and the
story
that's interesting that you say that
your generation are the biggest sellouts
um
that's really interesting actually um
because i feel like uh my generation
actually don't have any hope you know
because like you know you call yourself
a fighter right um
and um you don't really find that much
with the young men anymore because they
don't sort of have anything worth
fighting for right
um
so who sort of like whose responsibility
is it are you saying that it's your
generation you didn't i don't know
inspire
my generation sold out you go back to
the 90s
and they started building all these ugly
houses
you know we were the ones that were
doing you know the whole new age
movement and then it became
shop until you drop
remember that phrase
yeah shut
up on that yeah yeah
that was my generation and then again
the younger generation they don't have a
fight in it they're not fighters they
don't teach no they're not
you know i was the smallest kid
and uh you know used to put us online
and i was always the shortest so the
bullies went after me right away
so as a little kid i learned how to
fight right away
and
and now now it's no don't
be nice view no no no no here
i mentioned about the wars
this is a quote
a passionate attachment to one nation
for another produces a variety of evils
that's george washington
europe has set of primary interests
which to us have none
or is very relation hence
she must be engaged in frequent
controversies meaning they're fighting
all the time
the causes of which are essentially
foreign to our concern
none of our business
harmony
liberal intercourse with all nations are
recommended
by policy
humanity
and interest
and i mentioned eisenhower before
our military organization today bears
little resemblance to that known by any
of my predecessors in peace
or indeed by fighting men
of world war ii
or korea
we must never let the weight of this
combination
endanger our liberties or democratic
processes
we should take nothing for granted
only an alert knowledgeable citizenry
can compel the proper meshing of the
huge military industrial
military machinery of defense with our
peaceful methods and goals
he warns us
yeah he warns us
in the councils of government we must
guard against the acquisition of
unwarranted
influence
whether sought or unsought by the
military industrial complex that is not
my quote that is eisenhower's quote and
there you got
lloyd austin
the head of your defense department that
sat on the board of directors of
raytheon how stupid can you be
yeah i think it's it's a sad situation
actually um i think i i've obviously not
seen what you've seen um but covert over
the last two years um was a real uh eye
opener um over the
the reality of how things are um but
actually um a lot of the stuff that i do
is in bitcoin so i'd really be
interested to hear your take on that um
because personally i feel and you might
have a completely different approach but
i feel like bitcoin is in some way the
answer to a lot of these different um
things that you're talking about um so
how do you feel about bitcoin well when
you look at the price of bitcoin still
around you know in the in the 20s and
where did it start from zero i mean look
where it is you know it's still worth a
lot of dough
and um people are going to be looking
for alternative currencies
the the the downside
is a strong upside particularly you know
other generations everything's going to
go digital
yeah
and that's that's going to be the big
danger i believe and that's when they
all go digital it's going to be years
and years from now because they're going
to go digital so they know every penny
we spent where we spent it how we spent
it so they could get their tax money
from it so don't have to keep working
and so when they go digital they're
gonna they're gonna do everything they
can to stop the competition but that's
way way way down the road that to me is
the biggest you know of the downside of
it the upside is
that in this time of economic chaos and
uncertainty people looking for
alternative currencies the only reason
the dollar is strong is because the
other currencies are so weak end of
story
and again look at euro it's now it's a
parody almost against the dollar
why because they have zero interest
rates look what's going on with all the
emerging markets look how they're all
going now people are going to be looking
for safe haven assets
both prices are go look like gold prices
on under eighteen hundred dollars an
ounce what are you kidding me i mean
gold should be skyrocketing with
inflation
and and and
and the wars going on and and the
uncertainty of economic collapse coming
so again what's going on
and the reality are two different things
the game is rigged
they look at the jp morgan gang
four four or five felonies they've been
convicted of convicted of
and
what happened they had to pay what a 900
million dollar fine for rigging the
precious metals market hey but jamie
dimon didn't go to jail
they rigged the market right in front of
your eyes the gowell game is rigged oh
they have a thing called the plunge
protection team or if the markets go
down too low or hey we'll let you know
to go along because then we're gonna
push the money okay gotcha man
[Laughter]
so again long term i i think it's a i
again i don't give financial advice
it's it's gold
silver
bitcoin
guns and a getaway plan
yeah i actually agree with you i like
that i like all of those i like the guns
and i like the getaway um the getaway
plane um but no i i do definitely think
bitcoin uh is um an interesting one but
just your point on gold why do you think
it's skyrocketing then right now
a white scale yeah because it's rigged
because
very important
i mentioned
earlier why the fed did what they did
and that was to keep markets from
collapsing and keep building them up
once the equity markets collapsed then
the plantation workers of slave landia
will know how bad things are the market
collapse the market your life is
collapsed you know that you've thought
about that but now you see how bad it is
when the markets collapse number two
when gold prices spike
people know how bad things are so
they're doing everything they can
we got the dollar and again the dollar
has no competition
none the chinese you want china's
destroyed its economy again by their
zero covert policies look at their pmi
that came out you know they're down in
negative territory
you know they they all
they destroy their own economy they're
again
we become the communist fascist states
western nations we've taken the commies
and controlling the people at every
level of life
and fascism by the merger of state and
corporate powers the facts are there
it's all there um but no i think it's
fascinating and i love everything you're
doing um because yeah people need to
wake up to all of this and realize that
you know things aren't um things aren't
good basically no i'm doing this i don't
i'm just doing it for me
you know yes i you know i i have no kids
you know i don't know you know family
it's just me i'm not doing it because
all i want because i'm doing this
because
i'm only me
because i'm a napolitano born in the
bronx born to be free
when i was a little kid
and i'd be shooting my mouth off my
father may rest in peace would say to me
in italian papagawa parrot
stop repeating what everybody else is
saying and think for yourself
yeah
when a situation would happen and i
didn't know what was happening
my mother may she rest in peace would
say to me
i hate cowards
yeah
that's
how i grew up
and now i see a nation
of people that won't think for
themselves they'll only swallow the
garbage
you know shove down their throat by the
media
and they're cowards
they won't stand up to little boys of
nothing
little cowardly boys like
newsome and cuomo
and here's the detail
the american people don't believe
anything
until they see it on television
yeah richard nixon
yeah that's brilliant
all right
so that's what's going on if we don't
unite for peace
we're going to die in war i mentioned
just quickly i owned three of the most
historic buildings kingston new york was
the first capital of new york state the
constitution that was written here over
70 percent of america's constitution
comes from here john jay the supreme
court judge was a judge here the siege
of democracy was sewn here i was looking
to leave the country
and in 2012 we were opening up the
magazine the trends journal in in
germany
and i've never been to berlin before
and
they're taking me all around east berlin
i said like this place is beautiful
it was grander than paris before it was
bombed out
yeah
and i'm saying to myself
the 1930s the germans with the height of
western civilization culturally spirit
of philosophically scientifically
you think of the great german names bach
bates overbought all these
where were the people to stop it before
it was all destroyed
isn't dresden lovely
why didn't the people stand up and fight
and be being an italian american how
come they didn't stop it in italy
the place was destroyed they destroyed
what took and now the same thing's going
on in ukraine what what things that were
built for centuries not being destroyed
we're the people saying stop we need
peace
i came back and it was a for sale sign
on the franz rogen house 1750's building
and i realized i said this is where this
and i bought the building when i came
back
and i said i can't run away
where am i going to run i'm only because
i'm an american
i said i bought these three buildings
the other building is a museum
because they represent the soul of
america it was the four corners of
freedom where the siege of democracy was
sown
that's why i bought them i'm in the real
estate business
so i'm doing everything i can
because as a visionary look at that look
what they've done with the covent war
they sucked the joy out of life it's
horrible at nine o'clock at night
people are still freaked out wearing
masks
little kids all screwed up
suicide rates skyrocketing
and every day fear and hysteria fear and
hysteria that's all they sell
so if we don't unite for peace and
freedom we're finished
again they didn't do it in europe
they didn't do it in ukraine
and they're not going to do it next
the people will march off the wall like
that
dumb enough to believe bush's wars
dumb enough to believe the colored war
you'll be dumb enough to believe world
war three
i think it was yuri besmanov that said
uh
people don't know until people don't
know until they physically feel the pain
like you don't know that you're like
going towards a gas chamber until you're
in the gas chamber i think that's what
your best man have said um but no this
is why i you know i enjoy having these
conversations um i i'm looking at the
chat now and i know everybody really
appreciated it um so where can people
follow your work and everything that
you're doing and maybe even get involved
i'm not sure
well the magazine is trendsjournal.com
trendsjournal.com and not because it's
my magazine
you know on the publisher but there's no
magazine like it we tell you what in the
world is going on what it means what's
next there's no trend magazine there's
nothing it's [ __ ] they'd fashion
trends you know not out
you know we're talking geopolitics
socioeconomics by the way i'm the guy
that coined the term clean food back in
in the 1993 new york times of the story
on it
bottled water trend back in the 80s you
know it's having a lot of years
and to donate is occupypeace.com
occupypeace.com
and i started the universal church of
freedom peace and justice
and that's imagine i started this in 19
excuse me in 2021
i got the domain name
freedom
peace
justice dot com
freedom peace justice dot com
that domain name should have been taken
back in
1994 when the when the internet
revolution began
that shows you the disconnect
of the human spirit
that i got that domain name freedom
peace justice and we do sermons each
week and this rally we had was also
sponsored in part by the church
well i'll leave all the information for
everyone um in the description on
youtube so they can check it out um but
gerald i want to thank you so much it's
been such a pleasure um i love your
enthusiasm and your passion for this i
think it's so important um so thank you
so much for coming on and thank you for
you having me on and thank you for all
that you do and for speaking out the way
that you do
oh it's my pleasure guys please don't
forget to hit the like button and
subscribe so you never miss a video and
we'll see you next week thank you so
much gerald thank you
the leia hill pancho